in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the control and regulation of
the pentose phosphate pathway two things
primarily are the rate of the actual
pathway and where does g6p actually go
okay so let's start with the rate so if
you recall of course is the oxidative
phase in the non oxidative phase now the
rate of the pathway when we're thinking
about rate we're thinking about enzymes
and the non oxidative phase really at
the rate at which it moves is entirely
dependent on the availability of enzyme
substrate so there are those trans keto
laces trans alba bases basically if the
substrates on which they act on are
there or in you know in higher amounts
or lower amounts that's going to
determine how fast this phase actually
moves so there's not really too much
complexity that were too concerned with
here but the oxidative phase is a little
bit more to it so if you remember the
oxidative phase was just taking glucose
6-phosphate turning it in turbulence
five phosphate and carbon dioxide going
from six carbon molecule to five carbon
molecule and creating NADPH of course so
we've made two of those from two nadp+
--is right and that was initially the
first step in that reaction the two-step
pathway was catalyzed by g6p
dehydrogenase right that was the enzyme
that catalyzes that reaction if you
recall now this this reaction pathway
eventually releases a carbon dioxide and
we talked about how reactions that
release gases like carbon dioxide are
irreversible and if a reaction or
pathway creates a gas and that path that
you know that end up that end product is
is sort of irreversible so we need to
make sure that we regulate this process
so this must be regulated or controlled
so that first step was glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase will be
regulated and the allosteric regulator
of it will be nadp+ so you can consider
nadp+ as an allosteric regulator
of g6p dehydrogenase okay so how does it
work
well what happens when there's high
levels innovate nadp+
and what happens and there's low levels
of NAD+ the simple short answer is that
high levels of NADPH or some innate high
levels of nadp+ will stimulate to 6p
while low levels of nadp+ will inhibit
this will to actually write that in red
inhibit it why does that make any sort
of sense
okay so g6p dehydrogenase the resulting
one of the resulting products is NADPH
okay so if there's a lot of nadp+ around
that means that we have too little
NADPH right most of it is nadp+ and not
the reduced form NADPH so there's too
little
NADPH around we want to make more NADPH
which means you'd want to stimulate or
activate this enzyme that creates it if
there's low nadp+ we want to inhibit
this pathway because that means that if
there's low nadp+ that means there's too
much NADPH most of it's in the reduced
form so we want to make less NADPH so we
want to inhibit g6p dehydrogenase so
that's a simple idea as far as the rate
of the Vandellas phosphate pathway and
how that's wrecked it regulated or
controlled but now the more complex
stuff where does glucose 6-phosphate go
this is a little bit different okay so
where does glucose 6-phosphate go now we
mentioned this briefly in the first
video on the pentose phosphate pathway
we said that it was need base so depends
on needs and we said it really really
briefly the needs of course that I want
to mention our NADPH our 5b or ribose
5-phosphate an ATP which is of course
energy we said in that first video that
if ATP was needed then the glucose
6-phosphate would go to glycolysis and
that if NADPH is needed we it would go
to the pentose phosphate pathway to
create the NADPH and this is true but
it's not that simple it's a little bit
more complex than that in fact there are
four scenarios that we can consider and
kind of think about what's going on with
this glucose 6-phosphate where is it
going okay so let's go through these
scenario by scenario first scenario
let's say we have or we need lots of
ribose 5-phosphate but we don't really
need NADPH
very much okay so let's consider that
first one thing I'd like to know is when
would this be the case so we lots of our
5p but don't really need NADPH
so our 5p we mentioned that that could
be used as a precursor to nucleic acid
synthesis um and NADPH was more for all
sorts of biosynthesis so we need lots of
our 5pe but don't really need NADPH so
in this case when we went with this you
know happen when would it happen it's
this is a case in which we need to make
nucleic acids of course nucleic acids
and that would be highly necessary for a
cell that is dividing right you do
replicate DNA for instance before a cell
divides so that's a case in which this
is this is sort of happening so if this
is the case if we need lots of our 5pe
but we don't really need NADPH what
should happen or what should predominate
in this case in this case we want to
make our 5p but we don't really care
about making NADPH so which phase
actually does that well of course it's
the non oxidative face right the non
oxidative phase creates our 5p without
creating an ad pH okay so let's imagine
how this would sort of work so we'd
start off with g6p and it would go
through go to fructose 6-phosphate
and we create some fructose 6-phosphate
now 406 phosphate can it can go on to
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate and then in
glycolysis right create and this
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate will be split
cut into dihydroxyacetone phosphate and
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate then that
hydroxy acetone phosphate will be
converted into g3p so at this point we
have four to six phosphate let's just
imagine that we have some more G
six-piece creating fructose 6-phosphate
so build up a produces phosphate we also
create a bunch of g3p
so now what happens is some of these
fructose 6-phosphate s-- and g3ps will
come together to make our 5p that
course these two reactions actually when
you write these in different colors let
me put them in let's say purple so this
step here and this step here these two
together are of course the non oxidative
phase of the pentose phosphate pathway
so what we're going to be doing is we're
gonna have it this glucose 6-phosphate
it's going to make some fructose
6-phosphate and some of those will go on
to make some g3ps and we're going to
have to fruit us six phosphates and one
glucose or maybe one glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate go each time going to make
three ribose 5-phosphate sand that
stoichiometry makes a little bit more
sense if you look over here so we're
going to have two fructose 6-phosphate
and one let's Rob hi three phosphate
coming together to make three ribose
5-phosphate we take two six carbon
molecules which is twelve carbons total
and one three carbon molecule which is
three carbons total so that's fifteen
carbons here to make three five carbon
molecules for a total of fifteen carbons
on both sides so what's actually
happening to the g6p in this case well
if we imagine we start off five to six
P's five up here right v g6 P's we're
going to take those five which would be
30 carbons total because each g6p is six
carbons so with 30 carbons to start with
and we're going to turn that into six
ribose 5-phosphate which is six five
color molecules 30 carbons so this is
the stoichiometry that kind of might
make this make a little bit more sense
hope that makes sense there so what
happened here we had two non oxidative
phase of the pentose phosphate pathway
go through so that we can make some r5b
without really making NADPH so that's
the first scenario second scenario what
if we need equal amounts of ribose
5-phosphate and NADPH well okay so we
want to make our 5p and NADPH what is
the phase for that right the oxidative
face let me write this in white the
oxidative phase
the oxidative phase takes g6p to our 5p
and creates that carbon dioxide and when
it does that of course we get that our
5p and we also get some NADPH out of it
right we get to every time that goes
through so I know I wrote equal amounts
up here and each one of these steps will
make one ribose 5-phosphate into NADPH
but essentially the idea here is that
we're making NADPH and our five people
at the same time so we're making sure
we're making two NADPH is for every row
1r v p but it's essentially it's not too
different if you think about it okay but
the point is we're making both in this
scenario what about the third scenario
this third scenario here what if we need
much more NADPH then oops what if we
need much more NADPH than we need our 5p
okay so when would this be the case we
want a lot of NADPH but we don't really
care about making our 5p okay when would
this be a case an example of when this
would happen is in the liver right our
liver needs lots of NADPH because it
makes a lot of fatty acids and for that
biosynthesis right we need a lot of
reducing power and our 5p is not really
necessary in that case you're just
needed a lot of NADPH so if this is the
case what should actually happen well we
don't actually have a phase for this
right we don't have a phase that just
creates NADPH and you know without
making our FIP the oxidative phase makes
both the non oxidative phase makes only
our 5p so we don't happen that makes
just NADPH what would happen here this
is a little bit tricky okay this is kind
of tricky but what are we doing
basically what we're doing here is we're
taking one glucose 6-phosphate okay
which is a six carbon molecule and what
we're doing with that is we're going to
fully oxidized it in two and to make it
into actually six carbon dioxide's so
we're taking one six hundred molecule
and fully oxidizing it I'll put that
here oxidizing it fully to six carbon
dioxide's okay so how do we do that okay
so this is a little bit tricky but try
to bear
me for this okay so what we want here is
really what we want is only the product
of the oxidative phase right we just
want that product the NADPH but we don't
want that are you 5p product okay so how
would this work well one thing for sure
is that we're going to take this g6p and
convert it into R u 5p and get some
NADPH out of it okay so that's
definitely true okay we're going to get
this we're gonna get to NADPH is here
from this oxidative phase okay and of
course we're going to knock off a carbon
dioxide right so I'll put that maybe in
green okay so we're going to also get a
carbon dioxide out of each one of those
steps okay but then what happens so this
part here is the oxidative phase then
we're going to take this ru 5 P but we
don't want this right we don't care for
this especially because immediately it
can actually be turned into our 5p but
we don't want this either right we won't
we don't we don't care to have this so
what we're going to do is we're actually
have this go to g3p and 2x f 6p v8 via
actually let me put that in purple those
those arrows just to kind of stay
consistent with fee the fact that I use
them for the non oxidative phase earlier
right so now we're going to go backwards
right in the non oxidative face so here
this is the this this is the non
oxidative phase right we're taking our
Phi P and going back to g3p and f6p so
what happens then so now we're going to
go back and basically go through
gluconeogenesis we're going to take this
g3p and this DHAP and bring them back
together to make fructose 1 6
bisphosphate and then to make 4 to 6
phosphate and then we're going to have
the fruit of 6 phosphate go back to G 6
P so this whole process here is of
course gluconeogenesis right we're gonna
have gluconeogenesis going on we're
going to have the non oxidative phase
and we're going to have the
oxidative phase up here right
so there's a lot going on in this one
okay but what ends up happening in terms
of the stoichiometry so let's say we
started off with six glucose 6-phosphate
so we have six times six carbons 36
carbons to begin with we want NADPH out
of this for sure so we go ahead and we
make it we take all these glucose
6-phosphate
turn them into six ribose 5-phosphate
and we make a bunch of NADPH cool we're
also making these these carbon dioxides
here so this thirty six carbons end up
thirty of them remaining these six five
carbon molecules of our 5p and six of
them of course are released this carbon
dioxide's
then we take this these are five PS
which were which were right here right
and we're going to have them go in the
non oxidative phase alright so actually
it might be helpful to to number this
may be number one would be here right
that first step the second step or the
second sort of pathway or idea that we
think you guys is the non oxidative
phase which we have here and then the
third one we can have this schooling in
Genesis going on there okay so the
second thing we have ribose 5-phosphate
we have six of them that we created here
and they're going to go through the non
oxidative phase right and they're in it
so we've seen before that three ribose
5-phosphate make two fructose
6-phosphate and one glycerol by three
phosphates well if we go from three
ribose 5-phosphate six we're doubling
that number there so we double the
numbers for Virchow six phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate as well start
off with 30 carbons here then we have 24
here and six here okay which is us still
30 now what happens well now these
fructose 6 phosphate and glyceraldehyde
3 phosphates these are of course the
glycolytic intermediates glycolytic or
gluconeogenic intermediates now what
they're going to do is go through
gluconeogenesis and create some glucose
6-phosphate so we go from 24 carbons
here 6 carbons here and then we're
actually going to make 5 glucose
6-phosphate so we have 30 carbons total
that would equal 5 glucose 6-phosphate
so if we go through and calculate the
overall reaction we can sort of cross
out anything that's on both sides of the
of these these arrows here so we created
6
ribose 5-phosphate and then we use them
up we created force for just six
phosphates use them up to glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate to use them up so all that's
left is we have six glucose 6-phosphate
there and five here right and then these
six carbon dioxide's but with these
glucose 6-phosphate s'right these five
can get crossed out and then we cross
out just six of those right and we're
left with one so we go from one glucose
6-phosphate to six carbon dioxide's so
the overall reaction is one glucose
6-phosphate six carbons to six carbon
dioxide's and we create a bunch of NADPH
and effectively don't create any r5b
okay so that's that third scenario the
last scenario is if we need NADPH and
ATP so what should happen and
predominate here okay so um we want to
create NADPH and ATP so we want the the
the phase that creates NADPH is the
oxidative face and the thing that
creates ATP is of course Baikal assists
so we want those two things to happen
okay so the oxidative phase is of course
turning a glucose 6-phosphate into real
O's 5 phosphate and then we'll get some
NADH is and it bphs excuse me - NADPH is
out of this and then to nadp+ is Goan
then of course we get some carbon
dioxide out of there - okay so that's
definitely that's what that's the
oxidative phase and we want glycolysis
to occur so what we're going to do is
we're going to take any of these ru5
peas that are made turn them into our
five peas now these are 5-piece can go
through makes them for just six
phosphates and some glyceraldehyde 3
phosphates now those things will go
through through glycolysis of course
right so again I I need it make sure I'm
consistent with these colors so this is
the non oxidative phase here all right
going through to make those and then
then we have is glycolysis happening so
now 406 phosphate will go down to
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate this will be
cut into dhap and g3p DHAP will be
turned to g3p so now we have a buildup
of g3p
now those g3ps can be oxidized turn into
and turn into pyruvate and when that
happens in glycolysis we're going to get
2 ATP's for every g3p that we have ok so
basically what happens is the the r5 P
that's made here is taken to 2
glycolysis essentially right via the non
oxidative phase to be used for energy ok
so now we're getting two atps for every
g3p that we get here ok and then of
course once we have this pyruvate that
pyruvate can be further oxidized form or
ATP or using a biosynthetic pathway
whatever is you know necessary so as far
as the stoichiometry goes here we have
let's just imagine we have 3 glucose
6-phosphate so that would be 18 carbons
total and we turn that into if each one
of these goes through we get 6 NADPH and
6 6 nadp+ is going into make 6 NADPH is
right 2 for each of the glucose
6-phosphate and then we create 3 carbon
dioxides
and we have five pyruvate so if we ended
up creating 5 pyruvates that means we
must have died in 5 nadh is made ok so
we go from 18 carbons here to 18 carbons
here and what what is the actual amount
of ATP that we get right how much ATP do
we actually get well if we think about
it these 3 g6p is made 3 or 5 peas right
3 RI peas we keep coming back to that
number makes 2 fructose 6-phosphate and
1 glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate each
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate gives us
pretty much 2 ATP so we have 2 ATP here
from that one glycerol 3-phosphate
and these 2 fructose 6-phosphate when
they go through that each that has that
gets converted to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate and that split into dhap
and g3p DHAP it has to be
converted into g3p so essentially each
one of these four to six phosphates
gives us two g3ps
so two g3ps times two for justice
phosphates is four g3ps right and 43
peas times two ATP each will give us
eight ATP so we basically get around
oops we get around 1080 P total out of
this fourth scenario hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching
hey folks my name is mo food
I am a tutor I graduated from UC
Riverside with a degree in biology and
on graduation to add a little bit of
trouble with the wind miss you can tell
the subject that suited for our listed
here in the description below you'll
find my email address if you have any
questions and you'll also find the links
to two listings my university tutor
listing which is for in-person tutoring
and my Google helpouts listing which is
for online tutoring thanks for watching